headquarters here at comic-con and we
were sitting down with the cast from
Castle Rock Jane melanie bill and yeah i
want to ask you this this is a stephen
king project and so on is called it the
ultimate love letter stephen king why
and we're gonna figure that out today
Louis Stephen King is the king of car
mm-hmm and he sprinkles it with humor
and pathos pathos no there yeah I mean
it's the you know salmon dusty who
created the show wrote it they're you
know they're huge biggest Stephen King
fans and they wanted to sort of honor
the legacy of Stephen King like taking
all of you know combining his his work
and making something original out of
that so it's the whole the whole show is
an Amash to to his work how how is it
being back when Stephen because you I
mean you worked with him on of course
Carey so what's it like now and what's
the difference I owe Stephen King a lot
do you and yes because really Carey was
the first film of mine that anybody with
a seat so it's wonderful being back in
the Stephen King universe because I've
got to be there with these guys yeah
what was it like what was the feel
myself as the show feels buki well we
shot in New England in a town in
Massachusetts pretending to be mean and
I'm from California where things are not
very old but where we were shooting like
houses are 300 years old the
Revolutionary War took place there I
felt like actual spooky vibes from the
town and then I in the end you go to
like a like a haunted house tour or
something I didn't put the haunted house
tour but I went to a tour of like
historical houses did they feel spooky
well this one hotel that we would go to
sometimes I have this cool like clone
you in
they replay they advertise the fact that
as hunters yeah room yes it was like an
infirmary during the Revolutionary War I
think at some point yeah hmm it's really
wanted it's a great place but it's funny
cuz New England really is like I hadn't
spend much of any alright there barely
any time there at all and we got to
spend the whole fall there and like the
fallen of inland is incredible it's like
but it does have this it's like so in
the mornings you drive and you know the
trees are all bright orange and every
morning looks like this fog cuz it's
cold
music drive to set and it's like this
whole like fog it's really spooking as a
bunch of these beautiful cemetery in
fact we use most of our acting chops to
try to look warm really looks usually
what is usually what acting is yeah look
warm when it's cold and cold when it's
warm I love that you said there was a
lot of beautiful cemeteries I mean that
just lends its but they are they're old
and beautiful and we were 10 minutes
from Walden Pond and we were we were
shooting around Concord Massachusetts
and it was just
do you enjoy scaring the crap out of
people
it's fun to be in like to watch with an
audience to get a real vocal like
visceral reaction at people yet that's
fine but it's the cheek because you
don't do it
I mean you shoot it and then eight
months later people get scared yeah it's
a long paper flick maybe if you're doing
a terrifying sitcom yeah did a
terrifying sitcom about marriage I mean
who's just how terrified married life to
me bill want to ask you it going from it
and doing this I mean do you ever just
one dose of happy stuff yeah I'm happy
yeah that's it I don't know yeah it's
just happen this way but it's I like I
like dark stories dark characters it's
fun I don't like doing the same thing
over and over again so yeah I'll do I'll
do a happy rom-com next I think what can
you tell us about the new secret I tell
you we're shooting it and we're shooting
it yeah in Toronto and it's just going
well yeah obviously an amazing new cast
you know all the kids are adults and
yeah it's going I'm excited to see it
mm-hmm was it kind of you know you look
at how it took off and then people now
when you go out or they like anywise
today do they ever recommend do they
recognize you yeah yeah I think people
are some people are work were they just
going he's like some people are not
trying to do your exit
[Laughter]
have you guys your has been to comic-con
before wouldn't and what's the
experience you're like horror fans are
really enthusiastic fans so it's nice I
mean all you want is for people to watch
your work and then respond and people
will definitely respond yeah this is
your first time it's my first time like
in a professional capacity I've been as
a plus one before oh okay I thought
you'd saying you you've come dressed
before I was like no I've come with my
fiance and likes to see if you bet
you've been here before
I've never been here for more I'm
stunned at comic-con what has not really
no she's right the fans are just really
there for you it's a break they seem so
excited there must be a bunch of carries
walking around yeah there's got to be a
few petty lights - I think have you seen
a few I have not seen anyone with my own
eyes I've seen pictures you see they're
out there they're out there I want to
get like the mask and use my own I think
sure I don't think I need a mask you
have medical condition in this
[Laughter]
if you want to lover what can you tell
us about it well it's kind of a medical
condition it's kind of a psychic
affliction it's kind of a curse it's
kind of a blessing it's something that
sort of takes over in front of the shine
you can get in trouble you talk about it
if you want I'm terrified and then your
character is obsessed with all things
bad correct yeah what can you tell us
about your character my character is
yeah really fascinated and obsessed with
fascinated by obsessed with the McCory
I'm a cop and she I was describing her
before like she's like the fans here
she's like a fangirl and she's grown up
in Castle Rock and when Henry Deaver
arrives she's grown up like hearing the
legend of Henry deeper and she's like oh
hell yes let's go this is what I've been
waiting for and then she catches wind of
the man the kid found in the basement of
Shawshank or the oil container sashing
she's like really excited and it's just
trying to find out as much information
as you can
she's our little freak yes it helped it
was a weaving shawshank in there because
of course when people see sausage egg
they go biggle crazy it was fun kind of
weaving that whole thing and that story
and they're making a party it's great we
shot at this amazing prison
and in West Virginia West Virginia
penitentiary I think it's cool and which
is also haunted that's what I say I've
seen that on one of those shows yeah
yeah it's and it's like this beautiful
gothic architecture and that was because
it's you see it in the first episode
like some of the interiors our studio
but all the exteriors and some of the
interiors as well I think we shot at the
actual prison but we shot it like you
know for production reasons like that
during block five or something episode
five reps before but it was great being
in there because like as an actually
like being in the real place it just it
was a really spooky vibe there they used
to do there was like hundreds of
executions that took place at that
prison yeah I used to do public
executions where people could just show
up and they came to somebody and their
head flew off and they were like never
mind they're not public anyway yeah he
was like bottom-heavy so so and his he
was paying the head popped off so when
you're in your trailer you like you
always want someone with you or was it
like I took care of did you take care
yeah you weren't even there bring it no
is it what about homecoming
hey you played Julia Roberts mom right
yeah how is tell me a little bit about
that it's gonna be great yeah
I really I can't I don't know what I can
say about that I don't think I can
there's so much tell you anything about
it but she's wonderful and it's a
wonderful cast I have a really small
role you'll come on and then build your
brothers worked with Meryl Streep your
dad do you think you'll ever get a
chance to work with an arrow yeah I mean
I feel like you feel left out of it you
know you have any of course yeah
yeah no of course I feel like my dad was
just like apparently because they were
doing press for Mamma Mia and Marilyn
walked up to him saying I work but Alex
he's such an amazing actor I think that
my dad was really proud that Meryl
Streep said that his son was incredible
actor I mean yeah she's a legend yeah
you'll get your turn right yeah call me
[Laughter]
call me call me [ __ ] if you guys did
you have a chance to talk with or did
you know you read the Steve and stuff
but I mean has Steven seen all this is
he as he seems you know I don't know if
he's seen it have you had a chance to
talk to him no not at all no but you
know who would know Sam or dusty would
know the creators of the show I I think
maybe you saw the first episode I think
you seen all with it really that's what
I've heard
that's calling yeah I think it's family
all right well I'm sure you see it all
right yeah I'll let you guys go are you
they take a picture of okie and Bridget
oh if you wants you can take a picture
in our green screen areas
Green actually it would be great to
gonna take a pretty actually I was in
the picture today if you think longer
take a picture on our green screen here
do you think so